what's up YouTube back at Roseanne's
kitchen table with Ben and I I said
you're the movie guy then you humbly
said you're not the movie guy i'm still
counting you as the movie guy i'm more
of a baseball guy that a movie guys for
I just struck I mean I'm a loser my
profession but the I'm struck by the
recall that people have in the lines
that people give me like I don't know I
don't know man on look it up all I know
is every day I go to the gym in west
hollywood and then your face is right on
the TV right there t they love you they
love you in west valley we're t see the
the the the gay people older women and
gay men they love that's right they love
them that's uh that's our wheelhouse
yeah the uh uh and it's good i like that
but I mean but the thing i'm not most as
you move today of course as you may not
even know but I once again outraged the
Tim Raines only got fifty five percent
of Hall of Famer Tim Raines need to be
in the Hall of Fame please yeah Tim
Raines and then somebody else didn't get
in Larry King was very upset that Jeff
Canton get in okay but the point of this
is I water cure Genesis all right art
the point is I want to talk about movies
because we did another segment on movies
and this year yeah lot of sequels coming
out so we have the Avengers is coming
out obviously star wars are very excited
about that then there's gonna be
Terminator I think it's Terminator seven
am I right what religion seven away with
the other with the other big one uh that
address a park a Jurassic world oh man
Batman Superman also that is that this
year too i'm not even sure that that's
this year uh I don't think that's is
here they may be the next but point is
it seems like Hollywood can't do
anything but it's hard to believe it
would be a but I great but uh I think
it's interesting cuz we just did a
segment on how box office is down yeah
and it seems like the only thing they
can do is sort of regurgitate these
things I like most of them but you're
saying you you're you're not even in
super always anymore that I I'm some of
them stand out uh but then I instantly
forget them and I don't see how people
are that excited for another Avengers
like we had one it's gonna be the same I
don't write and at the end it'll be more
explosion at the end our Guardians
magazine fantastic I wrote that there's
an or as a repetitive or Denarius to
them while they're technically very
thrilling yeah are technically well made
and occasionally thrilling yeah but you
know uh you know captain america I like
I liked captain
America that was good but I and those
one great scene in the in the elevator
but I knew that I didn't care yes I you
know and I but I i know that i don't
speak for everyone but I there is an
incredible sameness to them and I I
whereas i get the excitement about Star
Wars because here's the continuation of
a cherished franchise uh in the hands of
a very interesting man very interesting
director so i get like I I'm a little
incision that and I I didn't I really
like Star Wars I'm not unlike star
elected fine i saw three times when i
was ten because everybody who was tense
or three times yeah um but i remember
very vividly thinking k Blue Star Wars
like but on 10 and all my friends are so
excited so uh kind your lack of faith
disturbing uh but I don't think that
we're I don't think that 2015 is any
more like since I don't know 19 to Tobey
Maguire first suited up yeah right I I
think there have been five spider-man's
five spider-man five spiders man spy
they were three and then two yeah right
bye spider-man a rich guy other people I
think they've been five my god like this
is not we're not you know and we just
finished the hobbit so the first in that
Matt six no third so six in the lord of
the rings trilogy in The Hobbit trilogy
in harry potter and twilight like this
is just the same it's just the same and
and holly was always done it yeah now
but is it worse that's the thing it does
seem worse to me now like just the
constant regurgitation we can't come up
with like an actual i don't really don't
think it's worse I mean you know one of
the most cherished movies that the TCM
fans have as The Maltese Falcon would
not be polar may aster citygrid street
in that and it was a remake you know it
every their stuff was a remake then well
um so uh but what I think is different
now is that the studio dollars are are
really fully invested in these
franchises yeah any sequels that's where
all the money is so that's where our
attention goes that's where all the
advertising goes and whereas in the
nineteen seventies and even into the age
there were still really high quality
non blockbuster stories being told on
screen with real actors and now those
seem like now we tend to think of just
there's two kinds of movies there's
these big giant superhero or fantasy
franchises and then they're indie movies
yeah and there and there's almost
nothing in this very little Argo yeah
you know like whether you liked our go
or not what you're looking for is uh a
movie about something interesting by
grown-ups for grown-ups yeah like I
don't care I I don't know why we've
decided to sort of make to devote all
our entertainment energy to pleasing 16
year old boys yeah like so what isn't
that what we do with everything
advertisers always want to go to the
kids and you know the kids don't have
the kids never have the actual spending
power they don't they're not want to buy
cars I guess they know what they're
doing right I guess they they dictate
what parents spend money on but as a
grown-ass man you know you're 16 go jerk
off yeah I'd okay with you havin
everything right so it's kind of like
it's actually a metaphor for sort of the
way Americans go in the middle class is
disappearing in toward the middle class
of these movies is disappearing while
the rich keep getting richer in the the
one percent of the movies that that's
where all the money what movies you see
lock I did lock is a grown up movie I'm
not even sure that I heard about a lot i
was about a door tom that's right it's
about it's about a guy goodness yeah I
is really frustrated in the ending it's
a big case any unlocks the door by just
give it away sounds a great movie uh
about a guy named lock Tom Hardy plays
in the entire movie takes place in his
car on the moat tensest night of his
life I want to give anything away for
personal reasons for work reasons and
all he does is take calls from his wife
his mistress his boss his the guy who's
replacing him at work the guy's gotta
convince to do something his kids and
they just keep calling while he goes to
a particular destination and he deals
with no wait no what I took what I tell
you and it is as tense a movie as I saw
this year listen unless he was dressed
like bein it's not for me and it's not
for America so forget about that movie
there's no way as a 30-something gay man
you
wanna see Tom RT ie when you dressed
like bein with that thing in the thing i
lo que le film critics gave in Best
Actor they made the right call a GoSee
lock it's a grown-up oh alright fine go
see luck